how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and everything relating to the
mcu and today we have some
really really interesting news in
regards to daredevil and
another character that could possibly be
coming to the mcu
daredevil is a character that fans have
wanted in the mcu for some time now and
i'm talking about
the real marvel cinematic universe as
most of you know kevin feige pretty much
came out and said that the marvel
netflix shows aren't
really that connected to the mcu which
of course is a bummer but
it means that they could possibly show
up in that real mcu so to speak
down the line especially with all the
rights to the netflix characters
reverting back to marvel
very very soon and today we have a
report that a daredevil
character could be coming to the mcu
quite soon
also leading us to believe that
daredevil may in fact make his way to
the mcu not too long after as well so
let's break down
this new report but first if you're new
be sure to subscribe to stay up to date
on all the marvel content and so you can
enter this week's giveaway for a chance
to win a black widow funko pop all you
have to do to enter subscribe
like the video leave a comment down
below so today's news comes from
charles murphy at murphy's
multiverse.com and
in his report he has talked about a
recent casting call put out by marvel
studios casting director
sarah haley finn and the casting call is
for an upcoming disney plush show
according to charles the casting call is
looking for a deaf actress who is native
american
first nations indigenous or latino and
also independent athletic and bright to
play a character
in their 20s now given the description
of this character and given the fact
that the character is going to be deaf
charles seems to think that the
character they're looking to bring in is
the character of maya lopez aka
echo and for those of you who may not
know ekko was a supporting character to
daredevil himself which means that
marvel could be planning on bringing in
matt murdock eventually
down the line after all by the end of
this year marvel studios will regain the
rights to
use daredevil for whatever means they
want they can use him in the mcu they
could use him in a movie or in a disney
plush show they could even use him on
hulu if they so
wanted to but if they bring him in he'll
definitely be in the mcu not on hulu but
in regards to echo let's talk about her
powers and talk about which disney plus
show we think she'll be in
maya is essentially a superhuman she is
actually much like daredevil and the
fact that she's deaf and her other
senses
are enhanced in the comics she's very
heavily connected to kingpin
in a very interesting and weird story
maya's father is killed by kingpin and
maya's father's last wish is that
kingpin
raises her as his own daughter she would
eventually go on to fall in love with
matt murdock but
kingpin would have her task to go and
kill daredevil however
throughout this course of events she
manages to fall in love
with matt murdock not knowing that he's
daredevil especially when kingpin sends
her to kill
daredevil and she almost does it but she
realizes that daredevil and matt murdock
are the same person
from there matt murdock tells maya of
all of kingpin's lies
and she goes and shoots him in the face
causing him to go blind
but he would eventually go on to regain
his sight so the inclusion of maya or
ekko could bring the inclusion of
kingpin
another character that many people have
wanted to see in the mcu for a very long
time
or just in a spider-man movie we did get
him in into the spider-verse but people
want him in the mcu and this could mean
that we could be getting daredevil and
kingpin eventually down the line now as
far as what series we can expect her in
it's widely believed that she's going to
be in the hawkeye series
she could perhaps be the antagonist in
the series something that she's done in
the comics before
and at one point in time she refused to
join the new avengers because of some
things that she did
so then she took on the mantle of ronan
that's right at one point in time
she was ronin in the comics now it has
been revealed that they are going to
explore
more of hawkeye's past as ronan in the
hawkeye series so perhaps this is where
she'll be introduced
but let me know what you think about
ekko joining the mcu and
daredevil and kingpin possibly joining
later on
leave your thoughts in the comments down
below don't forget to like this video
and subscribe so you can stay up to date
on everything relating to the mcu for
live updates you can follow me on
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof